realistic that girl kind of an oxymoron
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be taking a look at
lifestyle youtuber tara michelle and her
realistic that girl routine but first
let me tell you about my sponsor cook
unity as a food blogger and cookbook
author i spend a lot of time in the
kitchen but i'm also a busy mom of two
and business owner so there's a lot of
days when i just can't sometimes i don't
have the inspiration sometimes i don't
have the time sometimes i don't have the
ingredients and sometimes i just don't
have the drive so whenever we're down
south in the states we always stock up
on some creative signature meals from
cook unity so cook unity has over 50
talented chefs from some of the best
restaurants in the country working out
of regional micro kitchens instead of
massive production facilities so you
feel like you're getting a restaurant
meal at home basically you let them know
what you like and what you don't like
and you pick a flexible meal plan so you
can get as few as four or as many as 16
meals per week then you can select from
hundreds of meals that align with your
preferences and dietary restrictions and
they use all really high quality chef
driven ingredients the meals are
delivered fresh not frozen in
compostable recyclable or reusable
packaging along with expiration dates
heating instructions and nutrition
information and then a few days before
your delivery you get a text to make
your selections for the next week it
feels like one big thing off my plate
that i just can't screw up everything
i've tried is amazing and the menu
rotates constantly with a wide range of
different cultural flavors and
preparations so it helps to fill the
gaps with inspiring fun meals for those
nights when things just get so hectic so
if you want to try cook unity out
yourself go to
cookunity.com or click the link in the
description and use my code abby50 to
get 50 off of your first order of meals
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and follow me over
on tick tock and instagram at abby's
kitchen so if you missed my juicy take
on the that girl trend and all the ways
in which i myself cannot participate
then i strongly suggest you check out
these videos right here but in short the
that girl trend of tick tock has young
influencers sharing all of the
aesthetically pleasing ways that they
live their healthiest most productive
life and how they do it all before 9 a.m
that sounds fake but
okay
and while this trend may have initially
been a well-intentioned way to inspire
others to engage in acts of self-care it
has quickly taken a turn for the worse
not only does it perpetuate toxic social
media comparisons an unreachable
lifestyle and a superficial version of
self-care
but some interpretations may also
promote disordered eating so yeah your
girl is
not on board but i'm not the only one to
share my perspective on the trend so
today we'll be taking a look at tara
michelle's realistic approach to the
that girl day and will decide how
realistic it actually is
[Music]
i'm not entirely sure what i'm doing
with this thing but it feels good so
we keep doing it so far we're already
checking off a lot of the that girl
boxes with the early wake-up time glass
of water and skincare routine but as
promised i would say this is a more
manageable version like we're not waking
up at 4 00 a.m and chugging a whole
liter of lemon water or doing a 20 step
skin care routine followed by journaling
meditation reading and setting our
manifestations and intentions for the
day side note all of those things are
amazing and if you like doing them keep
doing them but let's be real they're not
so realistic for a lot of people to do
all those things before nine but yeah i
do think that this looks like a morning
routine that i could realistically do i
also appreciate the i don't know what
the i'm doing moment with the gua sha
because let's be honest does anyone know
what they're doing with that thing no
clue if it feels good to rub a rock on
your face great you do you rub away rub
a dub dub and i've decided i'm going to
be
that girl or like that girl in a
realistic way because those girls leave
things out they don't show you cleaning
their glass straws or their metal straws
or whatever they use there's a little
in-between moment health planning
movement of the body start planning the
day
[Music]
yes less perfection more relatable
content yes one of my biggest beefs with
the that girl trend is that it tends to
be really unrealistic and inaccessible
for most folks while pushing a
one-size-fits-all ideal of what living
your best healthiest life looks like and
if the true goal is to live a happier
healthier life then it should embrace
the messy spontaneous
less instagramable moments of the
journey not just the beautiful end state
it also shouldn't be something that adds
more stress and pressure to your day so
i like that tara is keeping it simple by
focusing on manageable yet non-specific
tasks like planning out her workday
moving her body and just feeling good in
general
[Music]
love that we're getting a nice balance
of protein healthy fats and fiber in
this simple combo though i would say
that most folks might need a little more
energizing carb action to get moving
first thing in the morning and since our
insulin sensitivity is actually highest
in the morning and our energy needs are
greater in the day it's advantageous to
kind of front load some of those carbs
in the morning meal and get that brain
food in so this could really be as
simple as adding some toast some oats or
some fruit on the side i also want to
point out that in effort to be a more
realistic that girl tara didn't fuss
about making this like a perfectly
aesthetic plate like we didn't even get
a hero shot which i gotta say i respect
because in real life who has time to
style their breakfast for the gram this
is why i kind of hate doing this kind of
vlog content because i just feels so
unnatural to let your food get cold
before you eat it so that you can get a
perfect picture only influencers
shooting content will style their
breakfast and even when the camera isn't
rolling they probably just go ahead and
shove that ugly ass breakfast into their
mouths too just an fyi just a little
behind the scenes hot tip i love waking
up early because there is so much that
gets accomplished before
like noon i mean it's 12 30 now but i
have been productive the day has been
planned posted by video for today i had
breakfast had my coffee which was
delicious so i am part of the 48 of
women who identify as a morning person
and research suggests that there are
actual genetic markers to this trait
which i think is kind of cool so if you
can't think clearly until noon you're
not just not disciplined enough you're
just who you are so right off the bat
this trend isn't going to feel good or
intuitive to like half the population
even more so if you're a man for whom
only 40 prefer the am wake up wake up so
as with all lifestyle trends you'll have
a lot more luck if you work with your
strengths not against them i'm actually
gonna go out and get a nice healthy
lunch something that i've missed for a
long time i haven't had in so long and
i'm really excited i'm going to walk
over there put my music in and just like
have a nice little stroll some sunshine
on the face
[Music]
i really appreciate how low fast this
routine is so far like tara didn't even
make her bed until around noon which i
feel is often at the very top of the
that girl to-do list side note i never
make my bed argue with me about it in
the comments i don't see the point when
you're just gonna mess it right back up
again but i love that she opted for a
more leisurely joyful movement in the
sun rather than a strenuous or
structured hit workout which is
something that i think a lot of us
forget just feels so good as for lunch
it looks like she's having something she
genuinely enjoys and is excited about
not something that she feels is
requisite of being that girl
[Music]
this is so good i'm so happy oh all my
canadians can agree that there is
nothing more pleasurable than a good
meal outside in the sun
and it is a beautiful day outside so i
am dying to get out there but i think
that while a lot of the that girl
routines are cost and time prohibitive
and therefore just not even possible for
most working people i think stepping
outside during a nice day to catch some
rays is something that most of us can
afford to do as for tara salad this
looks so bomb we're getting tons of
fiber and micronutrients from the
veggies protein from the chicken and
healthy fats from the avocado we've got
a little carbs in the tortilla chips but
totally room for more if she wanted
ultimately though i don't get the
impression that she's intentionally
cutting carbs as in one of her previous
what in a day videos she featured tons
of carb action with like a rice and
veggie stir-fry for lunch and mac and
cheese for dinner so i just remind you
that you can be that girl if you choose
to eat mac and cheese with your bestie
straight out of the pot sometimes a card
packed nostalgic meal from your
childhood is exactly the self-care you
need
[Music]
i like kind of burnt the gnocchi this is
the reality
you
know
okay you know what
it's fine trader joe's if you are
watching come to canada we will welcome
you with open arms an empty belly and a
full wallet trust me come to us but
anyways okay i love that even though the
burn gnocchi wasn't um very aesthetic
she was just like
nothing that a little cream and butter
can't fix a
men girl having said that this is still
like a lower carb low protein meal and
getting a nice balance of carbs and
protein increases tryptophan which
supports serotonin and melatonin release
so this can help to promote a more
restful sleep so to boost up the protein
here without compromising on flavor we
could sprinkle a few tablespoons of
nutritional yeast on top or add in some
canned white beans or leftover chicken
but i think to be
that girl and to do that girl things
just do what makes you happy that's
really all it is if that's working out
fantastic if that's eating yummy food
that fuels your body that's great but
you know what let's be honest we can't
do that all the time sometimes we have
to eat an entire pizza to ourselves
because that's what we feel like do what
makes you happy it's all about balance
mindset importance to only be inspired
by the highlight reels and not compare
your own life and like if you're not
doing something productive if you're not
having a productive day or you didn't
eat super well one day that you know
you've done something bad like you
haven't you know it's all about balance
and even those girls have balance in
their lives can't be perfect 100 of the
time i think we're all that girl it's
it's just genuinely how you feel about
yourself and i i'm that girl whether or
not i make my bed in the morning i'm
that girl whether or not i have a super
productive day i one thousand percent
agree and like i discussed in my video
on the that girl trend one of the major
issues that i have with it is that it
promotes a one size fits all health
ideal one that often presents a very
narrow and privileged definition of
health most folks don't have four hours
before starting work to dedicate to
their skin cassie decided to wake up at
4am that morning to get ready for school
[Music]
she needed to clear her head so please
know
you are enough if you slept until 10 you
took a rest day off the gym ate leftover
pizza for breakfast didn't make your bed
or haven't seen the sun in days
self-care is a lot more than a beauty
mask bubble bath and champagne in a claw
foot tub let's fill up this cloth with
bubbles that does sound really good
right now i also want to remind everyone
that whether or not a health trend like
that girl is problematic will often
depend on one's unique why so are you
going to that 6am spin class because it
gives you energy adrenaline and
endorphins that you genuinely crave or
are you dragging yourself through that
class to fit in with the that girl life
are you meditating in the mornings
because it brings you peace and calm or
are you just putting in the time to like
check it off your list our health and
wellness routines should serve us not an
external source like our instagram feeds
or public opinion so as you continue to
get bombarded with these healthy girl
routines and feel inspired to revamp
your own take a minute to self-reflect
on who the routine serves and whether or
not it even feels good to you if it adds
more stress pressure and obsession it's
not a healthy habit for you with that
said do i think that tara's that girl
routine is realistic well we had an
unmade bed a quickie skincare routine
burnt food and
we even ate real dairy
wow so it's nice to see an influencer
kind of like breaking the mold the
problem with this date isn't so much the
perpetuation of pressure to perform but
that it was sadly very low in calories
likely around 1200 to 1300 calories max
and i checked out her previous wedding
in a day video to get a gauge on
consistency and while it was higher in
carbs it still fell in this suppressed
calorie range as well so i just want to
remind everyone that 1200 calories is
the caloric needs of a toddler not a
grown adult it's very hard to meet
nutritional needs with so little food so
if this is not intentional restriction
but rather a challenge with consistent
appetite or early fullness i've got lots
of tips in my video right here for
adding calories to your meals but in
tara's case i think it really could be
as simple as just adding a little more
carbs to meals and throwing in one or
two energy dense snacks let's normalize
carbs as being cool for that girl so in
conclusion if watching videos of
people's healthy routines inspires you
to try new things and discover more joy
and calm in your day then i think that
they can serve as a great motivator but
if you take anything away from this it's
that this is a very privileged trend and
you are not less than if you can't
afford the time or access to all of the
rituals that girl prescribes most people
can't and if it brings you feelings of
guilt shame or anxiety trying to embody
a trend that doesn't fit into your
reality then we need to just let it
let it go
[Music]
but shout out to tara for helping to
kind of normalize some of the more
imperfect and slower moments of our day
that just feel good regardless of how
they look so on that note that's all
that i have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you